y para revista de prensa nos acompaña
como siempre Marta Moya Marta bienvenida
y buenos días para usted Hola María
Clara Buenos días bueno Comencemos con
la noticia que ya habíamos adelantado y
es este reportaje ilustrado de USA today
sobre el proceso de deportación de miles
de ucranianos desde Rusia sí María Clara
Este es un reportaje que ilustra Cómo ha
sido ese proceso de deportación de los
ciudadanos civiles ucranianos hacia
territorio ruso en estos más de 15 meses
de guerra este reportaje ilustrado está
basado en reportes de organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos como human redwatch
amnistía internacional el observatorio
de conflictos o la coalición ucraniana 5
am Estados Unidos estima que hay uno con
más seis millones de deportados
ucranianos a Rusia Ucrania dice que son
dos millones y que entre estas cifras Se
podrían incluir a cientos de menores que
es por lo que la Corte Penal
internacional pidió una orden de arresto
contra el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
en el mes de marzo el usai today ha
entrevistado a ciudadanos deportados o a
familiares que han sido deportados de
civiles ucranianos con los que se
reconstruye todo este recorrido el
reportaje empieza así su país ha sido
invadido y su hogar ha sido destruido
consigues escapar y sobrevivir en el
sótano de un edificio cercano entonces
un día y una voz extraña fuera los
soldados les obligan a salir de su
refugio y los dirigen a un autobús con
destino desconocido eventualmente te
queda solo en el país que destruyó tu
casa y mató a tus vecinos profundicemos
un poco en esto Marta Porque usted está
hablando de cómo suben a los buses Pero
cuál es el primer paso de esta
deportación pues María Clara según
retrata el usa today y los militares
rusos empiezan a detener ucranianos
mientras que estaban en zonas de
conflicto y que no tenían los medios
para salir del territorio y dirigirse a
zonas más seguras la única salida de
estas personas era aceptar un billete
hacia Rusia o bien detenían a estas
personas en las calles o bien los rusos
entraban entraban en los búnkers y les
obligaban a salir Black uno de los
entrevistados por el usa toe dice que
por ejemplo a su abuela la metieron en
un tanque a su madre en un autobús y a
él en otro autobús Y además que
aceptaron por miedo a represalias por
miedo a violencia o por miedo a
coacciones no y que muchas
organizaciones consideran esto como
crímenes de guerra y qué pasa una vez lo
suben a estos vehículos pues María Clara
según retrata Black este entrevistado
del usaid today viajaban durante horas
no viendo la destrucción a su paso la
primera parada para muchos es un puesto
de control fronterizo en una ciudad
ucraniana controlada por Rusia en estos
puestos de detención los rusos tenían
instalados tiendas de campaña o spots
gubernamentales como estaciones de
policía improvisadas allí tenían que
hacer filas durante horas para hablar
con las autoridades y cuenta y ya otro
de los entrevistados que por ejemplo su
familia fue desnudada en condiciones de
congelación en estos puestos de control
de los rusos mientras buscaban restos de
pólvora tatuajes procranianos o incluso
lesiones en sus cuerpos impresionante es
Marta y cuando ya lograban hablar con
los rusos que les decían ellos pues se
retrata este mismo personaje y ya que
los policías le revisaban desde las
huellas dactilares hasta el estómaban
fotos incluso eran obligados también a
rellenar formularios y los rusos les
hacían preguntas como tiene familiares
en el ejército o cuál es su actitud
frente a la policía o las autoridades
ahí ya también le revisaron el teléfono
le revisaron sus aplicaciones de
mensajes su historial del navegador o
incluso las fotos que tenía eliminadas
en su teléfono en este punto muchos
ucranianos fueron detenidos en centros
sin saber si los iban a liberar o no y
los que pasaban el filtro pasaban a
Rusia y los que no no se sabe muy bien
Qué ocurría sin embargo organizaciones
de Derechos Humanos sostienen que muchos
pudieron vivir o pudieron morir por la
violencia de los rusos y este reportaje
también señala que muchos ucranianos
fueron trasladados no a Lugares cercanos
a la frontera sino bastante lejos Así es
María Clara y es que los que pasaban los
filtros Ya pues se dirigían en otros
autobuses al otro lado de la frontera
rusa algunos fueron llegados llevados a
territorios del lejano Oriente ruso se
estima que 300 residentes de la ciudad
sureña de maripol fueron trasladados a
una ciudadana más de 9.000 kilómetros de
sus casas y una vez llegaban a Rusia los
dejaban en complejos deportivos o en
escuelas y muchas veces se llegaron a
congregar allí cientos de personas en un
mismo espacio a muchos los volvieron a
interrogar incluso les obligaban a
firmar declaraciones por los que ellos
aceptaban que los ucranianos habían
cometido crímenes de guerra a otros les
obligaban a pedir y a solicitar la
nacionalidad rusa Y entonces las
autoridades les daban un Bono de 130
dólares y los dejaban un poco a su
suerte en esos pabellones y una vez
pasaba todo esto cómo lograban
reconstruir sus vidas pues María Clara
este reportaje del yo sé tú de Dice que
una vez llegaban allí pues era la
primera vez en todo el trayecto que
podían ducharse hablar con sus familias
incluso saber un poco cómo estaba la
situación en sus casas luego a otros
muchos lo seguían moviendo de
localizaciones no no solo había un spot
concreto donde llegaban estos deportados
ucranianos Natalia otra de las
entrevistadas dice por ejemplo que su
madre necesitaba tomar taxis de una
ciudad a otra para simplemente conseguir
medicamentos y a menudo no tenían dinero
pues para buscar ni siquiera
asesoramiento legal sobre qué hacer no
muchos fueron despojados de sus
documentos ucranianos lo que dificultaba
también su salida de Rusia incluso
quienes tenían mínimamente los recursos
tenían miedo pues de volver a Ucrania
porque sus casas finalmente podían estar
destruidas por lo que dice eliose today
que al final estos deportados eran una
tenían como una doble huida primero de
la guerra y luego del país que pues
provocó esta guerra y es así concluye
este extenso reportaje del usai que es
bastante Espeluznante la verdad y los
invitamos por supuesto a consultarlo en
USA today Marta gracias por este repaso
a la prensa internacional gracias